was läuft schief in der deutschen
bildungspolitik reden wir drüber mit
einem mann der tatsächlich selber als
kind mehrere jahre zur schule gehen
musste mit olaf schubert bei damen und
herren
oder schubert
oder auch mal so allgemein was sagst du
zum bildungsniveau in deutschland man
kann es nicht wegkriegen es gibt ein
bildungsgefälle und dieses
bildungsgefälle wird immer gefälliger
und die gefahr ist ja dass jugendliche
die nur wenig zugang zu bildung erhalten
haben zum politischen extremismus
tendieren so und machen wir uns nichts
vor es gibt jugendliche die sind eben
nicht so die hellsten hoeneß nicht mehr
so nah dran aber es gibt ja jugendliche
die sich jetzt nicht so direkt für
buchstaben interessieren die wohnen eben
meist ein bisschen am rande der
peripherie so viele wundern direkt an
der s bahnstation dann hören die den
ganzen tag zurückbleiben bitte sagen wir
glauben und diese jugendlichen sind dann
oft rechts bis hin das geht bis zum
rechtsextremismus das geht so weit dass
man wirklich der am hof liegt und das
ist ja im endeffekt auch nur eine
normale biologische reaktion
denn das blut wird hier oben nicht
gebraucht
und hier unten kommt es nicht an also
wir reden dann in dem fall von einer
wander erektion
und das ist nicht gefahr für die
demokratie
wir sind denn deine erfahrung mit dem
deutschen schulsystem als vater von
mindestens bis zu fünf kinder
es ist ja aktuell auch viel von mobbing
die rede ja das wird allerdings finde
ich ein bisschen zu hoch gehängt eine
sehr interessante studie hat ja ich
glaube neun von zehn kindern finden
mobbing ja richtig gut und ich beobachte
bei vielen schülern eine sehr hohe
soziale kompetenz auch empathie und es
wird das mitfühlen und das wird auch
kommuniziert wenn sie sehen hat jemand
ein problem dann wird es auch
angesprochen und gesagt hey du opfer du
tust mir verleiht du [ __ ] aber wir
können natürlich nichts beschönigen es
gibt auch gewalt jetzt gott sei dank
nicht von meinen jungs von meinen
töchtern von den kleinen und da sage ich
immer passt auf mit gewalt erreicht man
nichts in eurem alter
also das ist zumindest meine erfahrung
also wenn man mit gewalt wirklich etwas
erreichen will dann halt wirklich nur
konsequent gegen schwächere ja also
dazu ist die schule das müssen sie lange
wir haben eben von sozialen
brennpunktschulen gesprochen es ist
tatsächlich so in gegenden wo er schon
viele viele armut ist kommen dann noch
und ob die kinder die wenig deutschland
kann man das nicht besser verteilen
das ist ja gerade die herausforderung
ich finde die integration darum geht es
ja auch die integration
unterschiedlicher kulturen muss früh
beginnen in der schule auch mit
freizeitangeboten dass die dass sie
lehrerin die unterschiedlichen kulturen
zusammen führt dass die lehrerin sagt
komm mal her
die unterschiedliche kultur also die
machen das ein professioneller die die
die anja studiert die wissen dann
stellenweise sogar den namen nenne da
sagen die hier
jacqueline und ahmet geht dann merken
die kinder gleich es geht bergab und was
müsste man machen um den beruf des
lehrers wieder attraktiver zu machen
es geht ja immer um abschlüsse na und
und das also das einzige oder das
wichtigste womit man als lehrer ja
wirklich abgeschlossen haben muss ist
mit seinem leben
es machen wir uns nichts vor es ist ein
schwerer beruf du kommst als
hochmotivierte pädagoge an so eine
schule und dann triffst du da die
irgendwie dieses ganze alle unmotiviert
irgendwie schlecht gelaunt und schlecht
gewaschen und so möglichst noch
alkoholfahne und dann merkst du dass ich
erst mal deine kollegen
also man muss natürlich auch sagen klar
viele jahre haben auch angst ganz klar
hauptsächlich natürlich wurden eltern
denn die kann man nicht mal an die
machen die geht die lehre ist ja alles
verantwortlich denn durch ruhen in der
achten klasse seinen vornamen immer noch
mit sch schreibt dann kommen die eltern
sagen ja der muss dazu schreiben
über begabt und lehre das nur zu blöd
dass wir erkennen also ich meine lehre
beruf attraktiver machen hat man man
kann einen alten fisch bunt anmalen aber
er wird immer noch stinken sehr schade
oder schumann und herren
[Applaus]